foreign
comes from Caleb in Georgia what do you
think about the new fed now and
centralized banking that's soon
happening in the U.S what I commonly see
is that they're gunning to take away
cash which goes against a lot of what
your programs are for please correct me
where I'm wrong I'm still learning more
about it but I'm curious to see what you
have to say
well the uh fed has announced this and
there are really two components of it
that matter
um the first one is is that they're
going to
modernize an Antiquated banking system
today when you uh for instance deposit a
check it takes three to ten days for
that check to clear the other bank
in a digital world that should take
three to ten seconds
for your check to be bouncing or good
when I when I put your check in my
account or vice versa or I make a
transfer to your account it shouldn't
have to sit there
three days to be verified it ought to be
able to just reach over to the other
bank find out if you've got some
freaking money in there and take it out
and move it over to your bank that's how
that's how a check is supposed to work
and that system is operating like the
1930s right now and they're trying to
move it into the digital world that is
as far as I can tell 100 positive what I
understand of it uh the second piece is
they're talking about issuing
digital dollars
yeah
which they already do so I don't
understand
uh I mean they're not saying they're
going to do away with cash they're
saying they're going to offer digital
dollars well let me help you George
when uh we move money from your account
to my account
and you don't use actual physical
dollars to go to the branch and make a
deposit you have by definition moved
digital dollars baby
that's what they are yeah most
transactions in today's world are
digital like 98 are digital it's not
cash transactions they're not actually
shipping boatloads of Hard Cash There's
a whole lot more money in our economy
with digital transfers
flowing around currency it has a current
than uh than cash and they're not
talking about doing away with cash in
this proposal nothing I've read anywhere
except maybe some you know dark web
conspiracy theories say they're trying
to do away with cash now the downside is
if they actually issue a template which
is what they're talking about doing a uh
it's almost a crypto of sorts of the
dollar is what it amounts to they're
going to issue you a digital transaction
that's different than the digital
transactions that we do now
the downside is the fear is that they'll
start controlling those
digital dosage that's the worry exactly
like ESG for instance they're going to
like try to say okay if you're uh not
going to be woke you're not going to be
able to use your digital dollars or if
we wanted to ration gasoline you're not
going to be able to use your digital
dollars but you can only use 50 digital
dollars to buy gas and then you have to
come up with other dollars of your own
Black Market dollars no it's not how it
works okay but that's that's the fear
that's out there DeSantis and Kennedy
both came out against this on the basis
that the Central Bank could overreach
their use of this as control and if they
try to use it for ESG stuff I would
agree if they're trying to control
currency and trying to invoke some kind
of power over it I I think that would be
a problem but I won't have all of my
money in their digital dollars I'll just
have it in digits in my account and
they're not going to force people to use
these digital dollars they couldn't
they it's the the conversion to that
would require a complete overall of
overhaul of the way we do everything in
our economy I mean think about it yeah
if you went from
have let's say you had to have a
certified number
to move money to venmo or to just to
reach over and move money from your
savings into your checking so you could
cover your Pizza Hut bill right or
whatever it is that this would be the
number of transactions this would
involve would be so large that for
government to get their arms around it
and control it I don't think it would be
possible on scale
I mean it would have to be some kind of
real fascism which honestly some of the
ESG stuff approaches fascism at times
because they've got this this they're
assigning values to their money they're
like religious zealots in a sense uh uh
to push their agendas and they'll stop
at nothing to do that but uh and that's
of course DeSantis and Kennedy's
argument is keep the Central Bank not
their job to invoke social change
their job is to run the banking system
you stay in your lane let them stand and
as long as they do that no harm no foul
with any of this
it now to the extent that they might do
that with the digital dollars it could
become it could become hairy and you
know uh it's a whole new place you could
get canceled
if you didn't meet the oh we couldn't
make the woke criteria or whatever right
and so you that that would be a problem
if your dollars freaking got canceled
that's a whole different thing so uh if
that got to that point then I think long
before then we would have fired a bunch
of people and
um Americans just don't tolerate being
controlled for very long
with rare exceptions we're stubborn like
that with rare exceptions sometimes
we're sheeple and we all go into our
houses for 90 days and wait on a virus
to pass but other than that we very
seldom are controlled
most of the time we don't do what we're
told
and so um which is good even if you
disagree with me you shouldn't have to
do what you're told that's called like
freedom and stuff so anyway that's the
downside of this thing that everybody's
moaning about but the implications are
you know I'm not losing sleep over this
I'm not going to bed worried at night
about what if centralized Banking and
digital dollars and cashless Society
this usually turns into fear-mongering
from the media and paranoia here's the
word here's the weird thing the faster
you can transfer funds
the more freedom you have
the more robust an economy is
the easier you can do a transaction the
more transactions occur the more
Prosperity you can endure
uh and the more freedom you have so the
the first part of this discussion this
ease of transfer and the shortening of
the the hold periods and all that
because they're updating the Antiquated
system is going to add way more freedoms
than the little corner of the digital
dollars might try to take away
so the net net on it I think is going to
be extremely positive although I'm not a
big fan of the fed and I'm not a
defender of the fed I'm certainly for
you bozos on Twitter not a shill of the
FED just to let you know but um matter
of fact I think some of the stuff
they're doing with interest rates are
some of the most asinine anti-economic
anti-capitalism stuff I've ever seen in
my life right now complete freaking
morons so there's the other side of the
equation if you were confused yeah now
he's been clear yeah but that's it I
mean you know so I overall this is good
overall this is good it's uh I I think
it's going to help and here here's an
interesting thing we can kind of parlay
into this too
I think what I said a few minutes ago
might be the most important part of our
little discussion on this I think
it's not the individual pieces of this
fed now thing the thing you need to
remember is
where there is no prosperity
where there is Extreme poverty
where the economics or economics are
hard to create where it's hard to start
and run a business where it's hard to
transact where everything's clamped down
where there's poverty
poverty follows a lack of Economic
Opportunity not the other way around
poverty is the result of uh economies
that are choked down where Freedom Is
Not So if you want more if you want less
poverty
statistically and historically if you'll
study the economies of the world if you
want less poverty increase Freedom
increased ease of transactions
increase ease of starting and release
less regulation on a business let people
go and do what people do Jefferson said
capitalism is what happens when you
leave people alone
amen and that that when you do that
people nations rise up out of poverty
why do you think the poverty level in
the U.S is so much lower than it is in
developing countries
Freedom that's why land of our freedom
matters economically